we got a show today watch it
[Music]
[Music]
Gary B
hey everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 179 of the
askgaryvee show
I'm uh what a weird mood today I hurt my
neck in basketball I ran into somebody
like full throttle so weird I literally
was referencing RAM man from he-man
during my audiobook yesterday and I like
literally became Rain Man but much to
Mike's credit though I am turning a
little weird when I wouldn't happened I
thought I was done but I think I'm built
up some neck muscles and was able to
absorb the impact so there's that uh no
I'm an interesting mood there's a couple
things I really want to talk to you guys
about number one the barter page I'm
really infatuated with this 50 book by I
know several of you've done it already
it's really funny first of all I don't
know if you've seen the barter page we
can't link we could do it right here
this is where I'm going there there's a
bunch of book deals that I'm doing
including for a thousand books you can
come and spend an hour with me I'll get
into another way of doing that in a
second but the 50 book by is me
recording my voice in anything that you
want one of the first ones that came in
was me recording something for an alarm
for somebody's buddy around an
inside-joke I'm like reading this stuff
so like if you want me to wake you up
India I think I think I should make you
one just says because we're friends what
do you think about the idea of do you
have an alarm yeah and is it like the
end yeah I have like three and they're
all different sounds Lizzie made me take
that because I would always like scared
you know that way but I will record
something for you like hey Rick get the
cop like you know something good like
that or like you're gonna crush to the
hey I have a feeling I'm gonna say a lot
of that and so I'm excited about that so
check out the barter page would love to
have you do some of that stuff a lot of
you are in for ten twelve fifteen books
I want to amp you up I want to get more
sales and I want to get you something of
value check that out number two the
thing that I'm really really excited
about February 23rd from 10:00 a.m.
Eastern to 6:00 p.m. Eastern in this
room
I will be streaming live on meerkat
Facebook live periscope and probably one
laptop thing we're debating Google
hangout or spreecast or something else
I'll be live for all of eight hours I'm
gonna have some special guest stop by
and what we're gonna be doing is the
super 8 day everybody's gonna buy eight
books as a refresh rate at vaynermedia
comm is up already I think that's what I
think that's what Alex said we'll
confirm that but I'm pretty sure put it
up right here you rock stuff on
whoever's lonely you didn't
black-and-white yesterday's episode you
did somebody was tweeting that you
didn't you did respect I'm sorry super 8
at vaynermedia comm you can start now
who's gonna do it only on that day but
I'm starting now if you buy eight books
send the receipt into that put it up
again like it there like it everywhere
all eight book receipts if you buy 16
will print it twice this is what's
happening gonna be in this room and here
we're gonna be going while talking on
crazy three people are gonna be
screaming I'm gonna be answering
questions like a maniac and it's gonna
be like a telephone I'm gonna keep
repeating that if you buy a book send it
a receipt somewhere out there somewhere
I don't know where the printers are
we're gonna be literally printing
receipts if you buy 32 will print it
four times and we're gonna come in here
at the end of day in a bucket I'm gonna
pull one name and I'm gonna give away
the thousand book deal to that person
we're gonna I'm gonna fly you in us only
for now I'm debating international maybe
North America only now sorry
global but it's expensive but I'm I
might I don't know anyway debating I
pull our name I'm gonna fly to New York
I'm gonna put bring you in for a meeting
it's gonna be an amazing 24 hours for
you or 12 hours for you in New York City
hopefully I pick somebody that's local
so I have to pay for the flight but you
know gonna pick that I'll get to spend
an hour and you can pitch me your
business we can jam I can interview for
your podcast whatever whatever you want
to do with my time I respect that
so knowing so many of you are buying two
and four and six books because I've been
following I wanted to create this eight
book level that has that big prize and
if you know anything about me you guys
saw it at Vayner day there might be some
other random prizes because I may feel
bad a lot of think I'm gonna sell a lot
of books I'm super excited bout it so
one last right hook before I start the
show if you buy eight books or if you're
planning on buying a books or if you
already bought
like eight bucks send in the receipt to
super 8 at vaynermedia comm we're
collecting receipts they are open now
for the contest cool India let's get
into show George asked what changed the
most in your company growing from the
founding team to 500 people what changed
the most I mean you know a million
things changed I started understanding
the industry I like being an operator
that learns the industry by doing
instead of reading so there's no reading
oval B's book or reading at age I
learned and so I think my ability to run
the company it increased tremendously
that founding team is six or seven or
eight people we're all kids all of AJ's
friends they've matured they're men now
they're no longer 22 they're getting
close to 30 which is insane you know I'm
just a much bigger company so we have
different dynamics everybody knew
everybody intimately now that happens in
pockets we have a tremendous culture but
like not every person knows everybody
not even close anymore so you've got
that dynamic we're in all sorts of
cities were a big company we're growing
up company it's a very very very
different yet the energy is pretty much
the same the mission is the same which
is help clients whether they're an NGO
nonprofit or selling bottled water help
them sell stuff communicate at the best
possible price in the best possible
channels to reach the biggest possible
audience to create that business result
and more importantly in that let's treat
each other tremendously well and have a
real real community here because
continuity is what I'm going for because
continuity builds speed one of things
that people understand about businesses
when you have continuity I use football
a lot I'm gonna use it sorry for people
don't follow but when your offensive
line when all five of those guys play
the whole season together because they
work as one it's really magic it's
really quite interesting when you really
understand how football is played it's
it's really a team sport more than
anything when those five playing the
whole season together or two seasons
together or three seasons together and
they have that unity and continuity they
flow they flow and that's what I love in
businesses the reason I value my people
so much and why I want to make it so
great for them is I want them here not
because I'm some weird evil like cult
overlord
it's because continuity breeds speed and
I value speed more than anything and so
we're not as fast as we used to be
because we're a little bit bigger but
I'm proud of the speed and the
scrappiness in the entrepreneurial
spirit we have at 600 that is still at
least a solid version of the first date
Thank You Alan like Alan Jack Vaynerchuk
AJ AJ yeah it's another from aging about
do you know about AJ's request in third
grade to be called Alan for a week no
but now I'm gonna call him Alan Alan
asks as we've seen you hate wasting time
but how do you adjust on days nothing is
going right well there's no such thing
luckily no I mean there's no I mean I
don't remember a day where nothing went
right I mean first and foremost the way
I really deal with it if we want to get
then about this and a lot of you know
this is as long as everybody's healthy
everything went right
I always quantify when business doesn't
go well I default quickly to a business
is [ __ ] it's all about life you know
like my kids look how cute my kids are
look how thank God my parents are live
like I quickly switch from I don't dwell
you know I'm not good at dwelling I love
speed and I don't like wasting time
dwelling complaining wishing hoping you
know pondering how you wish it was is
the single biggest waste of time in life
and in business like the bottom line is
we all wish thinks I wish I was six foot
four the single best looking guy in the
world and the quarterback of the New
York Jets that has won 19 straight Super
Bowls I wish that I wish that I mean I
just wish that I wish that and-and-and
in the same way that that's funny is the
same way to wish that like that deal
went through or that employee took the
job or that person didn't quit or that
concept didn't work out I mean I've had
multiple divisions multiple strategies
here at wine at Wine Library at
vaynermedia that haven't worked in the
last 12 months
yeah we're dismantling it and so much
like anything else you just it's like
next it's the next play using artistic
stuff like if you're doing a Broadway
play what are you gonna mess up a line
and just stop and just cry onstage
you just got to go to the next line I
mean just gotta keep moving forward and
so how do I handle it easily I'm champ
on this issue I'm a champion I am an
absolute champion on this issue meaning
like I'm prepared for the punches in the
face I'm expecting is not to go well I
it's kind of the way I prep for jets
game Saturday night nobody likes being
around me because I'm just devastated
it's all bad we're gonna lose this is
what's gonna have it we lose you know
like I'm subconsciously like that but
unlike the Jets where I say that
outwardly these guys can tell you I'm
only on winning an offense at all times
that's true sure we can make one okay
Chris asked if you could what advice
would you give yourself in high school
you know the thing that I've answered a
lot on this is like I'd hook up with
more chicks you know I've talked a lot
about that any you know look I mean it's
the advice that I give you guys now as
an old 40 year old right which is like I
wish I I was I wish I was a little bit
more patient because I was so hungry to
prove to the world that I was a winner
because I was such a loser in school
that I just worked every minute I didn't
you know go to an extra keg party I
didn't you know like spend an extra go
away in a weekend and just do something
different or like I punted everything it
just went completely and utterly into
I'm gonna build businesses this is who I
am and so you know maybe I would have
gone on the ski trips so I can be good
at skiing now and into it
like maybe like I would have done maybe
I would have rounded out some stuff but
the truth is in a weird way in the same
way that I just talked to you about the
last question I don't know like it's
also good I don't I'm probably like if I
could speak to my high school self is
that what the is not the way it's yeah I
mean I think that'd be my high school
self was sitting here be like hey man
good news
it's gonna go well it's gonna it wasn't
even better I liked it then too I was
antsy and I wanted to like everyone like
and I'm still a little bit like that but
I was super happy like I wasn't like
some outcast like it yeah my teachers
and my friend's parents thought I was a
loser but all my friends loved me so
let's call it what it is when you're 15
you don't give a [ __ ] about teachers and
parents you want your homie used to
think you're cool so I was super happy
it was just that I had a chip on my
shoulder because I'm like I'm gonna be
all-time great I really believe this I
really believe it's the same way that
Harrison Ford about his acting or LeBron
about his basketball or or some music
Whitney Houston better singing like I
really think young Whitney Houston and
5th grade is sitting there and saying
because she's killing in a church she's
saying nobody knows how great I'm really
gonna be like I literally felt that I'm
like I can't wait for them to all really
know so there was a little bit of like I
can't wait to have my coming-out party I
was I was antsy for the coming-out party
but I'd probably say like hey man it's
all gonna work out great like like just
do everything you think you want to do
it like just follow your instincts it's
gonna be good Corey unions I know I
haven't gotten to high school readings
but I've talked to a lot of people on
Facebook in different places in my high
school and like it's interesting the you
know I wasn't outwardly like running
through the halls and telling everybody
that I was gonna be you know like I
think the one thing that felt really
nice is like a lot of people have sent
me emails like it's so nice to see you
doing well you were you were really nice
in high school like that makes me feel
nice the thing that I think a lot of
people are starting to realize on
dailyvee that I'm just a nice guy too
because I'm actually quite competitive
and confrontational on askgaryvee on
stage like most list of people consumed
from me on while I be TV I'm panning
stuff ironically is me and my
competitive zone when I'm not in
business or on basketball court I'm
actually kind of completely the other
way and I think that um that was nice
like that's been the end I don't
remember being like I get I forget that
people are just mean in high school and
I was so self-confident that I never got
dragged down to do that
that's good ya can be a rough time for
all people yeah it was rough for peeps
for some peeps many some that are
watching now two high schools the glory
days to jockey Jacque Jacque Jacque
wishes High School is still rolling it
sounds like a Pokemon like pug Jeremy
asks how do you decide when a social
media platform is going south and no
longer worth putting energy into
engagement when something's big myspace
Twitter right now is interesting to
watch Google+ Tumblr when something gets
big you just watch organic reach on
Facebook it's not super hard like you
know when it happens to snapchat oh I
remember these when I had 25,000 people
watching my stories and I could get
2,000 people to screenshot now I've got
400,000 people watching my stories and I
couldn't get and I couldn't get a
hundred people at the screenshot like
it's very easy it's data you just stop
feeling it when I used to send an email
and sell 400 cases of wine in an hour
and then set up seven years later it
took me four weeks or four months to
sell that same 400 you're like wait a
minute
and then you just look at the data
you're like oh look the open rates are
not as good the click-through rates are
not as good the data is there like you
know like you just you just respond to
the reaction either you're stale and
people want to tune you out or the
platform has an issue and so you've got
to decide is it you and you became the
same old song and dance or is it that uh
that the platform sucks
usually it's not you even though I have
a lot of the same themes a lot of you
watch me for the energy or the routine
or the excitement of it all even though
you're starting to grasp my thesis ease
more importantly there's just so many of
you I mean leave in the comments right
now did you just meet me in the last 30
days YouTube Facebook leave a comment
did you just meet me the last 30 days
and there's always more people like
nobody knows who I am
it's true don't say that yes I know but
the look in your eyes the happiness you
are like way more famous than even like
two months ago
tell me everything no it's true you've
been like like have you been like
recognized more on the street yes but I
know my own stories yeah exactly tell me
your stuff my stuff people recognize me
in the park like they'll be like oh
you're India chromatic actually I was in
San Francisco over the holidays in a
museum with friends home and someone
came up to me on the west coast and said
oh you're India from the askgaryvee show
and we're your friends like what the
[ __ ] my friend was like what is that
what you do are you wanna show YouTube
show yep unspoken word says hey Gary be
my son loves digital media and snapchat
they want to be producers any advice for
why Jen oh my god dude look how awesome
that dude terrace I would so kill it if
I had that hair yeah I mean look
unspoken means I think that the number
one piece of advice I could give you is
make them feel like they can actually do
it if that's what they want to do you as
their parent creating that permission
for you to say yes you can is real now
no 8th place trophies yes you can but
when they put out something and
everybody on YouTube says it sucks you
look at them and say the market said you
suck let's try again so it's this
balance of I completely believe you can
but let the results be the results don't
fake the results I actually see more
it's unbelievable how bad people aren't
parenting I'm not kidding I'm really
this is a real hot-button issue for me
like this could be the transition of my
career I really think perfectly parented
when I write it transitions my career I
really do because I'm passionate about
this like as I'm getting closer and I
have a six-year-old daughter and I
meeting other parents I'm not calling
out any parents I know if you're
watching but I've been picking up on
some themes and I'll tell you I hate how
many people reverse it i watch a lot of
parents that are like you know literally
like soccer they're like I don't know
Rickie if you're gonna be okay yeah you
know Johnny's really good like no
self-esteem building and then they play
a they lose ain't nothin and are like
Ricki into the great job it's literally
the reverse of what I want which is like
India you can be the greatest operator
of a museum in the history of all time
and then when you have your first
exhibit if it doesn't go well you say
look it didn't go well and let's let's
backtrack and figure out why and then I
would give her cuz I my little india i
knew how she likes to read i give her a
book of like the guy or the girl who
started three businesses and failed but
then on the fourth one figured out the
learnings from the three and killed it
like the KFC guy encouragement matters
but reality matters just as much and you
have to create friction amongst those
two to create the perfect storm for the
young and moldable minds and the old and
moldable minds twist ending great
critique I need comments I need feedback
I have a trip to Boston on Friday I'd
like to read feedback dailyvee my
snapchat the askgaryvee show how you're
feeling how many books you want to buy
what you can do for the critique not
like I thought that last question got me
going bring in the kids and the
parenting I get going you keep asking
questions I'll keep answering them
[Music]